disclaimer I own nothing what's up
gamers and people who have interacted
with women it's your boy gorilla Mondays
here with another video that has nothing
to do with anything you can keep making
that not a spider-man channel joke in
the comments if you want but it's your
fault for making those views so
disproportionate so stop complaining and
listen to me talk about Mouse infested
pizza restaurants I say infested because
there's so many different types of
Chucky Cheese now the 90s scare Chuck
that Pixar reject guitarist Chuck and
all these severely outdated movie
references I recently attended the famed
pizzeria for my sister's birthday party
and I couldn't help but notice all the
things wrong with the restaurant now
that I never picked up on when I was a
pizza eating twelve-year-old without a
care in the world this establishment has
a lot of problems and I feel like they
could be making way more dough every
year if they address them in some way
pizza or otherwise now bear in mind a
lot of criticisms I have with the way
things are run might be very
specifically geared towards the Chucky
Cheese in my local area and the problems
it has may not be present in every
single store in the chain but it's not a
particularly bad neighborhood it's not
being run into the ground due to health
violations and it's been running a
stable enough business to have been open
all the way from my childhood until now
so let's assume that my Chucky Cheese is
a baseline and that all of them looking
to run pretty similarly
give or take one or two of the problems
I want to talk about so here's my pitch
for why I should be the new CEO of
Chucky Cheese CEO of cec weird all right
let's say they let me in the door after
I found out I inherited the company from
a long-lost relative Elvira style first
order of business is clean up the
branding within the store itself I can
stand in the middle of the store and
turn in a circle and see three
conflicting designs of the character and
I feel like as a kid that could just
make it confusing and harder to get
attached to the image of Chucky if he
has no consistency look at Ronald
McDonald even though clowns are [ __ ]
terrifying kids they'll crack a smile
and feel their stomachs girdle after
decades because they've kept the design
so recognizable and consistent sure 90s
skater Chuck is a little dated but that
could be played up as part of his charm
or if you want to modernize and commit
the whole way instead of half-assing it
and only putting his new design on one
in five objects in the restaurant neck
Chucky's cast of character sucks no one
can remember any of these other
characters like this purple whatever guy
what's his name mr. münch
what are his interests why do they call
him that they have so much potential to
have unique and memorable characters
that could in turn equal to all kinds of
new toy and merchandise opportunities
but they ignore them and don't do
anything with them again going back to
the McDonald's comparison people still
remember grimace in the Hamburglar even
if they haven't been used in decades how
about instead of Chucky being this
catch-all sports ball guy have each of
his friends specialized in a different
outdoor activity and have him stick to
skating and maybe guitar maybe this
purple gorilla thingy is kind of a
sci-fi nerd but he also really likes
soccer maybe this bird girl over here is
sort of like Chucky's will they won't
they love interest and she's a talented
rock climber who encourages kids to wear
their pads in case they fall because
they don't have the benefit of flight
like she does she can just be like
really outdoorsy and passionate about
nature anything's better than nothing
use your heads if you're gonna get brand
tie-ins or parodies make them relevant
this poster of Chucky as spider-man is
so old that Green Goblin is still on it
when was the last time men and black was
relevant safe for the nostalgia baiting
reboot that was inevitably gonna happen
in 20 years
Chuck Feld okay every kid in the
restaurant is gonna need their dad to
explain that one Jesus remember when ER
was a thing I don't look now that you've
repaired your lackluster character
roster get a brand tie-in with Marvel or
something and have Chucky in the gang be
corresponding Avengers since that's kind
of hot right now hell if you're really
desperate you can ask DC for a tie-in
and it still kind of work just put up
newer art on these walls that a little
kid is gonna look at and understand or
care about because these kinds of things
stick in a kid's mind it makes them
think of chuck-e-cheeses when they see
the official versions of these things
and they might want to come back for
their next birthday okay another thing
for the love of God find something for
the adults to do I don't see the point
in serving alcoholic beverages if the
place has nothing to do for anyone over
the age of like 12
hi Chucky
[Music]
maybe you have another section in the
place for some of the older kids with
some like edgy or arcade games I'm not
saying you need a Mortal Kombat machine
or something but like rail shooters
something just like a game that the
older siblings and the moms and dads can
comfortably play for one it drastically
expand the amount of time your customers
return because then the place still has
some appeal after they stopped being
tiny enough to fit into the disgusting
unwashed Sky tubes you know what else
you can do to make sure you got the
interest of your younger patrons on
lockdown
keep the immersion going with Chuckie is
a real guy who wants to show up at your
birthday and make you feel all special
like at my Chucky Cheese there is a
single small stage with one rather
unimpressive animatronic on it who
barely does anything the curtain never
closes on him so it really breaks the
illusion when the guy in the costume
room walks right by it and you go oh one
of them must be fake then you know when
you're like three
you just sits up there all day
performing for the birthday is that no
longer go here
[Music]
and at night he stuffs people into
animatronic suits are you drinking my
soda get the little guys some Wonder and
imagination to work with make them think
that after the curtain closes Chuck
comes from around backstage to hang out
with partygoers before his next set with
his band of animal musicians and yes I
know it's expensive but [ __ ] splurge
and get more than just one up there
performing why do you think people
remember Showbiz Pizza so fondly not for
the pizza look at all this stage space
wasted by this weird light display that
doesn't really look like anything and
these three TV monitors that are
essentially just background noise get
that out of here and make the stage
bigger it says a lot when the horror
comedy parody of your restaurant has
better representation and more likeable
environment than the real thing you guys
what else oh yeah get an employee small
enough to clean the sky tubes it's
disgusting in there it has the texture
of a wiffle ball bat covered in pizza
grease and pinkeye every chuck-e-cheese
needs at least one 5 foot tall employee
to get in there and wipe the thing down
put some padding on the floor those kids
knees are destroyed after like 30
seconds in there ok something else that
stuck out to me my sister and I spent a
few hours getting tons of tickets from
the skee-ball and that hit the button at
the right time to win a hundred tickets
thing we got around 700 during our trip
we walk up with our harder and currency
at the prize table and the bored
teenager behind the counter goes all
right what do you want
and then my 11 year old sister replies
with
because the prizes suck like they really
suck nothing that's affordable really
jumps out it's just stuff like sidewalk
chalk or crayons or really cheap toys
you can get at Walgreens for like 50
cents
they have all these plushies of
characters that kids don't know slash
care about and then these Mouse head
things they don't want just Chuck's
severed head as a toy here my dad came
up with an idea because I was
complaining about all this stuff the
entire time we were there how about a
toy that's a little mouse themed robot
that's a pizza slicer they got like a
little blade wheel on the bottom and
they could have adorable whiskers or
ears or something it could be like a
secondary mascot and you can draw a cute
little art of them working in the
kitchen like little helper robots plus
you blame the weird slicing lines on the
pizza on them instead of the chef's
incompetence sure it kind of conflicts
with the sports theme of Chucky but when
the hell is his interest in sports ever
factored into anything other than being
an excuse to sell plush soccer balls
that no one wants next to stale cotton
candy I can't exactly give a rundown of
an entirely new selection of stuff to
have in the prize section but just
generally throw in some work balance the
only cool stuff is so wildly expensive
that a kid would need four or five
friends grinding tickets from one of
those hundred ticket payout things for a
few hours to be able to get and at that
point only really one of them could
enjoy it if you're gonna have some of
the prizes be insanely expensive make it
something multiple kids can enjoy
together like a board game or a package
of multiple action figures of various
cool characters or like I don't know
just put a Nintendo console up there
with four controllers and whoever's
birthday it is gets to be the one who
keeps it at their house and as for the
little stuff that one kid could afford
on their own how about something with
more longevity than crayons and slinkys
and um bracelets there's a million and
one small cheap toys you can stock that
could make neat collectibles to be
played with by the cheer ins either
commit to using more brand stuff or make
your original stuff more interesting or
both because I realize that ever since I
was a kid I'd walk up to the prize table
and I'd have that same reaction my
sister did and my cousins and my friends
and the other kid in front of us in line
who we've never met it was all the same
confounded a long
a groan of indecision and pressure from
tired parents looking over your shoulder
and fighting back the urge to just shout
Jesus Christ just picked something
already
I like Chuckie Cheese when I was a kid
it was an amazing place that me and
everyone else my age loved going to but
these days I get the suspicion that
interest is dwindling because the
company makes such poor decisions with
how the stores are run plus their public
image is probably in shambles right now
because that guy in blackface accusing
them of recycling pizza is like a
Futurama joke you recycle everything and
that sandwich you're eating is made from
old discarded sandwiches
nothing just gets thrown away the future
is disgusting
typical 20th century attitude and it
doesn't help that there's a mega popular
franchise of games poking fun at their
theme and implying these restaurants are
a hotbed of murders and confusing
half-baked lore Scott cough and prove
that you really can tell an epic saga by
just being very vague and obtuse about
the details and then making it up as you
go along only to pretend in the end that
you had it planned out from the
beginning he should write Star Wars
movies anyway I submit this video is my
formal campaign for presidency of the
company and I guarantee that under my
leadership you cheeseheads will be
making more cash than your restaurant
has dirty small fingerprints on it do
you know what I don't get about chucky
cheese I mean look at all these famous
little Mouse's you know look at look at
all these dudes look at them now look at
Chucky [ __ ] cheese what's what's
wrong with him why is he this dirty
little gray color who designed this
Mouse
he looks [ __ ] disgusting why anyway I
edited this video so if you want more
Mouse related content subscribe to me
cuz I'm releasing episode 164 for Mouse
review this one's gonna be a good one
this one's gonna be a doozy
[Music]
[Music]